ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from new york city from the
gas digital studio our good friends
where it all started
and thank god
didn't finish
but we are we like to come back here and
and visit the good people
at uh gas digital studios new york city
contact them
for studio rental i believe they do that
don't they do that producer
they do
contact them ralph sutton louis
gomez
drop the j
beautiful studios here in new york city
manhattan
uh get in here and record you're you're
a day away from being a millionaire
podcasting's the new thing
you've got to take don't you have
conversations with your friends monetize
them dummy
you're what we're waiting for get over
here to gas digital studio rentals
probably reasonable
nothing's too much money to invest in
your future
ben avery you just got back from vienna
with your wife we usually don't allow
you to speak much on the show but you
did have an interesting um
uh experience uh traveling to europe
with your wife
um
i of course let you go to take a week of
time five days to galavant with your
wife
in
europe you're welcome now we don't
usually let you speak
um but now i think was an exception to
that so could you
summarize your trip to europe in one
word
[Laughter]
pick a word
in which you believe
best
summarizes
all the things you've learned while in
europe with your wife
on my money on my dime
delightful
ben avery
we covered the queen's death on our
patreon we're not going to retread
uh that territory
is that the term retread
yeah re-uh re uh trace retra uh trace
our steps no
i mean retread
look up retread
which you should have done
re-tread means what go back over a path
or once thank you that's it so i'm right
we're not gonna do that we're moving on
to women in our own country there's a
new show out
hillary clinton chelsea clinton
it's called gutsy
and it's about women who are brave
and i you know me
often at the end of a long day
when i have done everything i've done
i've
made people laugh i've dealt with my
incompetent employees my
uh horrific uh agents and uh
managers and people
that are impediments to my success when
i'm done navigating
that
i come home
and i turn on the tv
and i i i say where are the brave
women to watch
why are there not more
because these
these women that the clintons have
chosen a spotlight are gutsy
apparently not all women are gutsy but
some of the these women are and many of
these gutsy women are also very wealthy
and famous
which is interesting
i don't know
so hillary
one of the episodes is with a
white an ex-white supremacist
did you know that i did not know that
hillary clinton
our real president
speaks with an ex-white supremacist on
the show
gutsy
and there's a clip of that somewhere
where this woman
is happy
to because now what the ex-white
supremacist does
she goes around the country trying to
get other people
uh to stop being hateful
i think that's what she claims to do
and
hillary
[Music]
is very impressed by this
and hillary
and this woman it's an unlikely
kinship
they have so
are you finding anything about this i'm
finding this article on yahoo right now
i'm going through it yeah it's it's
beautiful and i don't you i'm not you i
don't usually fall for this type of
emotional stuff but it is kind of
beautiful
uh yeah shannon foley martinez a former
white supremacist from georgia who uses
commute canoe trips down the broad river
to help rehabilitate women leaving hate
groups canoe trips yes so if you're in a
hate group
she shows up with the canoe goes get in
this canoe you nazi [ __ ]
and then she you go down the river with
her i like this yeah what a good
business only in america
can you have a business
putting nazis in a canoe
and trying to get them to hate jews less
it's a
there's economic opportunity everywhere
so this woman who used to be a in a hate
group
now she's in a canoe
hillary clinton
and her
now do you do you have i i there's a
clip of this let's find this clip and
it's this woman
talking about how grateful she is
to have been contacted
by
hillary clinton our secretary
of um
hate groups
francis i'm going to send this to you
it's it's it's beautiful i like this
they paint with megan the stallion
hillary and chelsea clinton you'd think
they'd go away at some point the
clintons but they don't
they never go away
they're in their mid
hundreds
they're both fat now
they're walking around the hamptons and
she's like wearing a big frock
looks like she's in a big painting smock
bill's just out of it because he's a he
had a heart thing he can't [ __ ] he's got
no
he doesn't want to live anymore because
he can't [ __ ] he's a vegan
he looks dead he looked like he died
years ago and he always has that weird
look on his face like he's in the middle
of a stroke and he's walking down the
beach
with his morbidly obese elderly wife
that daughter
they have and a few secret service
people
and they're in the hamptons and they're
just kind of like
just the last few days
the last few hours
and no one really cares anymore and now
they're just kind of like in the
entertainment business like the obamas
and really like donald trump's always
been in the entertainment business but
like when you leave office in america
you just go right into the entertainment
business you start producing
documentaries and tv shows the obamas
how to deal with netflix and now
hillary's doing this show gutsy you just
become
part of the uh entertainment big stars
big stars on the show who's on the show
they're big stars you got uh goldie hawn
yes cat a cat hudson is it is that a
kate kate hudson kate hudson you got amy
schumer yeah gutsy kim kardashian guts
brave wanda psychics
brave guts megan the stallion i liked
that they didn't go with nurses teachers
in bad areas i like that no i like it
because we i'm i'm happy that they're
not pretending to care about those
people because no one really does
so everybody just wants to see like
what's goldie hawn been up to no one
wants to see a teacher from detroit
what i'm happy that hillary didn't go
the route of like let's spotlight
non-famous
non-celebrity women who have balls who
are gutsy who are brave who are making a
difference let's find
celebrities
multi-millionaires
and shove them down people's throats and
tell regular people
how brave amy schumer is
how hard it is to be amy schumer
how difficult it is to live in martha's
vineyard and how gutsy you are to take
the private plane to martha's vineyard i
like that
i think it's good is there anyone
regular on the show besides the is the
one non-celebrity the ex-nazi [ __ ] uh i
watched the first episode because it's
free on apple tv okay yeah apple tv they
they do talk to um
uh some some comedians in the show okay
not any i'm not high high level
comedians uh so uh no but no no no
layman type of uh man how about a female
cop
that i did not did they leave out a
female cop so here's what i would say if
i'm thinking of gutsy female jobs right
just off the top of my head you're a
[ __ ] and you're out there working
what's a gutsy job i think cop
female cop right because men have a
physical advantage in strength sure
true
maybe a mental advantage in certain
capacities not going to comment on it
i'm not a doctor
the point is i don't know i'm just
saying
you're a
if you're a
cop which is a horrible job anyway
reserved mainly for uh stupid and
aggressive people can we say that
dumb and aggressive people for the most
part become police you need police but
it's not the best and brightest sorry if
you're a cop and you're listening to
this you know i'm right they're like
it's like a backyard wrestling kind of
you know
animal or something that usually becomes
a cop the most of the people i know
who are police were literally criminals
up until the moment they decided to
become police literally like the weekend
before
and a lot of during training
uh during uh what do they call that uh
when you go into the police academy yeah
when you're in the academy they were
still kind of criminals
right up until graduate like and some of
them are just criminals cops drive drunk
they they commit crimes really they do
but that being said because it's not a
celebration of the police
what we're saying is that of a female
cop it's a ballsy job but i guess
there's something uh that
hillary just doesn't want
to to highlight a female cop no
she doesn't want to do it she doesn't
want to do it so we're not going to make
her do it but that would have been
interesting to me like like if you said
a female gutsy job let's say a cop
or maybe a teacher in the inner city
like dangerous minds remember michelle
pfeiffer in the movie dangerous minds
where a
white woman went into a school you want
to talk about the most racist movie ever
a white woman
went into a school and the only way she
could deal with minorities was to be
like a marine
and remember like that first
first scene in the movie she's like
she like people are trying to fight her
all the time remember that and she's
just like she's constantly in a stance
and they were like dangerous minds
and then she came in and she took them
all out to a restaurant and they're like
yo what's the filet mignon
and she's like it's a steak
remember that
that was like one of the original white
savior movies dangerous michelle but
that i would think ballsy
female the job uh teacher in the inner
city
cop
so do we have this clip of this white
supremacy this is actually kind of
beautiful francis was that it in that
article because she left that
you know movement of hate and
discrimination uh to try to you know
live a different life and she's now
trying to reprogram others to help them
get um beyond all of that but more than
that we're looking for women who are
gutsy not just on behalf of themselves
but on behalf of others we had two-way
conversations with the women we were
interviewing but we kind of want a
two-way conversation with people
watching it and we hope it sparks a lot
of conversations in in families and in
you know groups of friends and everybody
else secretary clinton speaking of that
give and take you interview a reverend
in the rebel hearts episode where you
open up about one of the gutsiest
decisions you've had to make in your
life which was the decision to stay in
your marriage
do you have a marriage that has been on
public display since the beginning you
said the gutsiest thing you ever did was
stay in your marriage that doesn't mean
that's right for everybody why did you
want to open up about that and the
reason she goes the reason that i stayed
in my marriage
is because my husband was the president
of the united states
now that's not right for everybody
because many people's husbands are not
the president of the united states but
she goes me and my husband
we've killed people together we have
many many shady financial deals
we are blackmailing several people we
run essentially a criminal crime
syndicate together so it's more than
just um a marriage
but
i don't i you know listen go watch that
show gutsy
football fans the first sunday of the
nfl season is here on draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars and get 200 in free bets
instantly as an added bonus for week one
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion
it's simple bet on an nfl team to win if
your team leads by 10 at any point
during the game you get paid instantly
even if your team loses
what
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code tim dylan to get
200 in free bets instantly when you
place a 5 bet this sunday that's code
tim dillon only at draftkings sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the nfl minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details
oh and i just want to say i've been
using this draftkings it's phenomenal
i use it and i love it yeah you use it
too i use it and i love it i like that
you're getting into sports i love it and
i well i'm getting into bedding
if you or somebody you know has a
gambling problem crisis counseling and
referral services can be accessed by
calling 1-800 gambler that's 1-800-426 i
all of my friends use this it's it's
great it's reputable you can get your
money anytime that's the most important
thing with these sites yes you've got
back-to-back meetings aaron serrano
choice to take care of what's the secret
to clearing a to-do list i'm telling you
right now it's doordash right now it's
september so you know everybody's got
the kids back to school they're rushing
around the pandemic's over so
everybody's back to work you don't have
any time to cook so what do you do
you use doordash
i use doordash along with the
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks other household items in under an
hour i mean they've you can go on
doordash and you can get anything really
from deodorant to danish
and i just came up with that it's not
even in the ad copy it's kind of
brilliant that's nice yeah but the
reality is like
when
the big real estate company
uh prudential douglas helmet in new york
these have a great slogan from manhattan
to montauk
great slogan i would do doordash from
deodorant to danish
because you can get anything you want at
any time you want and it's so easy
and it's so
everything's at your fingertips but you
don't have to leave your home
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and 0 delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code tim dillon don't
forget that's code tim dillon for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change terms apply and i want to say
i've been using this i've been shocked
how fast it is it's amazing i've been
using doordash for years
how about freedom fest what's it called
it is freedom fest and uh yeah yeah so
the trump scam is ending exactly how
people would imagine it would in like a
field
this is exactly you know it would end
exactly how it started which is like it
started in the lobby of one of his
buildings and it will end in like an
open field in northern kentucky in
northern kentucky and you know less and
less people are showing up to these
things and then the people that are
showing up it's really sad
like that's the word for it it's
actually terribly sad
like it's really just people that are
lost
and they need something like when you
walk up to them
one woman's like people are talking
about like reiki healing and yoga and
she's wrapping that up with like q anon
stuff and they're they
they're just people that are so lost
in their lives
and they have nothing
and the world just confuses them it it
boggles their mind
so like they they need some type of
uh
you know consistent
like
they need somebody to consistently
tell them that they are
part of a
movement
and
it's so sad
because all of this
could be alleviated by like taking up
tennis
for most of the like most of these
people
with a simple hobby
a simple hot like like if they took up
crocheting
most of the people that showed up at the
capitol right
simply need
some form of
restoring old
tables like to just restore an old
woodworking
anything before
you're in a field
talking about jfk june you're being and
i saw this thing that jordan klepper did
on it and i was like oh this had to be
like years ago it's like last week
they're still doing it
the queuing on people are they're still
they haven't been dissuaded
by nothing coming true they're still out
there
against all odds
and you want to kind of grab some of
them and hug them and go like
stop
they they they have the energy of
addicts of drug addicts like you wanna
you know when someone's a drug addict at
christmas and they're you know they're
skinny and their teeth are chattering
and they're just sitting there and they
keep going to the bathroom and you just
wanna grab them and hug them and go
you're gonna be okay you just have to
imagine a different life
you want to go to these people in a
field in northern kentucky and go
imagine a different life how about
fishing
you can it's a d you don't have to talk
about jfk junior anymore
it's over
someone let them know it's over
but no one has
no one has let these sad fox know that
this has ended
for a quick minute it was like a
zeitgeisty thing to do
and people were into it and celebrities
were throwing things at
like all
movements it's gone
it's down the river yeah q even stopped
he didn't even care no one's even
involved
you are taking this and running with it
now
the scam the people who are perpetuating
the scam are gone
they are on to new scams
i remember what this is like because i
tried to sell mortgages in 2009
when it was over and you would call
people and go hey are you looking to
find it and they would go what's wrong
with you
they go the the world ended six months
ago the economy crashed there's nothing
left here for you
and we would just make cold calls every
night trying to pick whatever flesh was
off the bone
and there was none and that's to say
that when i see the q anon people it's
so sad to me because it's just like oh
any hobby would do any hobby would
suffice truly
cooking anything you don't have to be
that particular about something to just
devote your life to other than showing
up in a field
and buying trinkets
and whatever they're doing and they're
setting up tent there are tents like
it's the san gennaro festival except
instead of sausage and peppers they're
selling shirts with jfk junior's face
it's so incredibly sad
it's a sub like the gathering of the
juggalos is so much better than this
like the gathering of the juggalos in
cave and rock or wherever it is is so
much more hopeful and positive of a
subculture to be a part of
it's crazy so
but
for the people that still want to do
this i don't want to dissuade you
so we do have an advertisement of
freedom fast oh well it's it's not
necessarily an advertisement but it's
the trailer for the documentary that is
debuting here at freedom fest okay
they they really only made a flyer for
freedom fest which i have the full
lineup it's wild let's talk about the
lineup at freedom fest all right so it
was it wasn't now it's the uh i got it
right here okay so you could watch gutsy
or you could go to freedom fest so
opening it what a great country oh yeah
you have it here pulled up yeah thank
you
so
during the a block i don't even know who
any of these people are but it's just
you have trump bikers the trump bikers
i no one know see here's the deal now
they they have no just get the flyers
just get the flyer up
because
nobody knows who any of these speakers
are this is over
the trump thing's done it's been done
sorry
apologies
i mean i i can't imagine people are
still into this
they're still showing up in a field
for this nonsense yeah i know can you
imagine like on the car like on the way
there in the car do you think anybody
has regrets do you think anyone on the
way there in the car goes like
yeah remember when we were going to
these things and there used to be so
much traffic
there's there's no traffic anymore
that's good huh so you go well i don't
know about that yeah well there's no
traffic remember a couple of years ago
man it'd be backed up off the exit now
but now we could just kind of fly into
this do you think any of them realize
there at the end they're the last of the
mohicans just the very final the final
the dumbest of the dumb because they now
have the the the they're the biggest
morons they're they are the stupidest if
you are at freedom fast
you are the dumbest of the dumb
except for the people who go next month
they're dumber than you and every month
until it's over until there's 25 people
two years from now
in like a small campground
it's a big lineup so at the end you have
can you show it and show it to us
francis could you could you bring up the
flyer
but uh so you have uh
eric deiters then you have seth dylan
who's president of the babylon b then
you have candace owens eric trump
kimberly guilfoyle then donald trump jr
then fireworks then uh the 2000 mule
screening which is the big documentary
that's statement you bring your own
byob it's byo they're not serving
alcohol they're not but you can consume
it and you should
and it's family friendly
it seems that way bring the kids
bring the kids bring grandma grandpa
it's as fast to celebrate freedom it's
happening right now actually
in kentucky as we record it's happening
right now it's happening now
the festival of lights
the festival of freedom
and people get up and give speeches
and it really does get it goes q very
quick like
people are like they're gonna i can
already anticipate the comments we're
like you're actually conflating
the queue with the it's actually
different it's not that yeah it's not
that different it's not that different
you're in a field
you've gone to a field
on saturday on your day off
you've gone into a field
to listen to people
that it just has never worked
didn't work when he was in office it's
not working now i mean it's
you know
but that's okay because people enjoy if
it's a fun day if it's a fun day
and you can go and get [ __ ] up and
drink
and you're like yeah it's [ __ ] huge
and you get real loaded
and you go yeah get that shirt get that
let's go brandon shirt and you got a
little spending money you go out there
this is burning man
for a certain group of people
this is burning man for people that go
to bob's big boy
this is their burning man this is their
playa
the playa is a field of kentucky
the radical i forget what they were the
term the ethos of burning man it's
radical self-reliance their radical
self-reliance in in this field is byob
bring your own bottle of booze
bottle of kentucky bourbon
instead of taking lsd and by the way
they don't even need the psychedelics
that's what's great because they're
living in a world where jfk junior's
alive and he's coming back i mean
they don't even need acid acid might
sober them up
a little hint of masculine might make
them start thinking clearly they're so
out there already
that if you took a burning man person
and sat them down at the height of their
trip i mean rolling
and you took one of these people stone
cold sober
and sat them next to each other and
interviewed them you would not know who
was on drugs you would go the burning
man person seems to make a lot of sense
the bernie man person would be [ __ ] up
they'd be like man i just realized that
like there were energized orbs of energy
it's like you're me and you go okay
[ __ ] a little new agey then you ask
these people what's going on and you go
well it actually all started underground
and that's where it will finish
and there are bases underground right
now the moon does not exist the earth is
flat and you go oh
interesting you don't really need drugs
i'm a conspiracy guy my whole life and
i've you know had more legitimate
discussions about conspiracies maybe
i'm not gonna say than any other
podcaster but i'll say i'm in the top
group
of podcasters that have entertained
conspiracies bringing people on
and i don't even consider them
conspiracies right i i brought people on
that have written books in alternative
history that have looked at things and
when i come to a
staggeringly different conclusion than
the mainstream media we've had
documentary filmmakers we've had xcia
agents john kiriakou all of them on on
the show okay we've thought about this
realm of life
more
than most people ever have
and it's crazy to watch
people that had no idea
about anything that have no background
that have no
experience with this thought
have their minds melted as i've
explained
many times
and
they're all wrong
about everything
except they're right about
the fundamental thing where it's like
well the things are [ __ ] up and people
are lying to you that's correct
but every every tree every route that it
goes from there
it's just none of it's real
covet the beginning of that they were
like it's fake this is actually a
disease that trump released it because
hillary's
was gonna kill people the one she
released was gonna kill people trump
released this one because he needs it
because it was a cover for a mill that
was again it was on all the blogs it's a
cover for military operations it'd be
three days of darkness that it
nothing i mean none of it happened zero
zero zero happened
and they're not dissuaded by any event
and they're going so it's like that's
why we we
you know
that's why they should be made fun of
because they're stupid
stupid people should be made fun of
just like the same people that think
hillary clinton cares about women should
be made fun of because they're dumb
and the the reason you make fun of
stupid people is because eventually
they're they go away and their ideas are
less potent
so when someone does something or says
something that's stupid you go oh you're
an idiot you're this is stupid
it's it's not it's actually a nice thing
to do for society it's a good thing it's
a necessary thing to do is when you go
actually
the earth is flat the moon's a spaceship
donald trump jr never died he's still
alive princess diana's alive michael
jackson's a lot when you start saying
[ __ ] like that you go oh you're a
[ __ ]
lunatic and you're dumb
you're not even like
i guess the argument is that yes there
could they be dangerous or everything
sure but they're actually just dumb
and that's even
that's even
to me it's like maddening
when someone is stupid
i mean we were around someone recently
that was so dumb
it was
it bothered us
people can be so dumb
that they make you angry
this is true and you realize
that anger doesn't work because
they cannot help
being dumb
it's not something that everyone can fix
some people are duh
they're idiots
they don't have the capacity for
critical
thought and when they're around you if
you are a smart person just like fat
people probably bother non-fat i
probably bother like really in shape
people if i'm around them
and they're not like oh why aren't we
hiking up at 14 000 foot mountain right
now and i go i don't know we're gonna do
that
and then go well yeah that's what we do
so i go oh all right
it's like hot people
like other hot people because they do
hot people [ __ ]
like go out to be seen when you're hot
you like to be seen the whole point of
being hot is for people to see you
so you don't have to there's no reason
sometimes hot people do things other
than to be seen
people who are confused by that
they're confused why hot people go out
to do not much
it's like because they're hot and
they've worked on themselves so they
just want other people to look at them
in the same way that smart people you
ever around a dumb person while smart
people talk they don't understand why
they're talking they don't get it
because they're they're outside of it
they go i don't understand why why would
you discuss
this thing
or they're like trot and this is even
sadder they like try
to kind of follow along
and you could see the wheels and their
little head moving but they're they're
stupid people
stupid people are part of society
it helps if they're good looking
this really helps if you're dumb out
there and many of you are
if you're dumb and ugly you're [ __ ]
truly
unless you have a real good skill but if
you're dumb and hot
you have a if you're dumb and hot don't
try to get smarter try to get hotter
because there's so many people
that are too dumb to really fully
ha
and and it's gonna get worse they're
gonna get dumber so if you're a smart
person you actually have to go
underground
and when you're out of the world with
most people who are dumb you have to
just deal with it and kind of like nod
and go yeah yeah yeah and you just have
to kind of find other smart people
somehow you identify another smart
person
because it will eventually you are the
minor if you're an intelligent person
you are the minority of minorities here
you are the smallest group of people
on this planet right now
intelligent people they're go and they
will be killed unless you can figure out
a way
to just get away
but
dumb people and people that appeal to
dumb people are going to have the next
50 years is going to be a boon
for the dumb who appeal to the dumb
no one will make more money
nobody will get further then retards
the [ __ ] kings
the people that are slightly smarter
than the rest of them of the monsters
are going to do so i'll be dead
and most people won't be here
we're all we're on our way out in the
next 30 to 40 50 years however much we
have left
that being said
whatever is coming next smart people
are
going to be in tech
they're going to be dealing with
machines smart people are going to be
dealing with mostly machines
people that are dealing with people are
going to be idiots
but only slightly smarter than the
people that they're dealing with because
it's going to help
so if you are an intelligent person
because every dumb is everywhere it's
not just on one political faction it's
not in one part of the country it's not
just you know people [ __ ] on the south a
lot it's not that everywhere everywhere
if you're watching gutsy you're an idiot
you're in you're a dumb person
if you're watching hillary clinton and
her daughter
talk to a reverend about why hillary
stayed married and you're watching well
yes it's interesting because you know
she's opening up for the first time
she's never opened up before about this
it's there come in here honey
come in here you're dom i don't care
that you have a [ __ ] apartment in
cobble hill
and you graduated from nyu and you and
you just learned how to make spaghetti
van gaal
which has clams in it
and you brought the clams at the
farmer's market and white wine little
garlic little oil i don't care you're
dumb
it doesn't matter what the school you
went to says if you're watching hillary
clinton talk to a reverend
about her marriage
on a show called gutsy you're an idiot
and if you're in a field
watching donald trump jr
introduce a jug band
or whatever the [ __ ] going on there
you're dumb
and if you're listening to this show you
are not done congratulations
and if you're buying the products we
sell you are incredibly smart if you're
on a patreon you are even smarter
than that
you may be one of the smartest people on
in the world
but i'm surrounded by dumb people all
the time ben is the least dumb person i
can handle and he's dumb thank you but
he's the least dumb that i can deal with
on a day-to-day basis
he reads books he's trying to better
himself he's so
good
truly
for it for someone who's dumb
but he's gonna be smart
he's on his way he's almost there i see
like uh
there's there's you know every now and
then the lights go on and then they shut
right off
but then they go on and off and on and
off
intelligence is your your fully
i'm telling you
lately i've been listening to a lot of
podcasts out there you know and i you
know why
because i like information
you know what i've been listening to a
lot
um
there's a few podcasts about it's called
uh
uh
it's about the the it's when the women
talk
but it's they're like free
well
one reason it's been great to listen to
because i use my raycon wireless earbuds
to do it raycon's everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me rayguns gave you eight hours of
play time in a 32-hour battery life
radcons are priced just right you get a
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 50 000
five-star reviews three customizable
sound profiles earbud tap functions
noise isolation awareness mode
go to buy raycon dot com slash tim today
to get 15 off your raycon order that's
buy raycon.com
tim
score fifteen percent off your order
buy ratecon.com
tim we've been using these on the road
i use them every minute i'm alive
sometimes i'm feeling sad
and i don't know what to do
sometimes i sit at home
and i am feeling blue
and my therapist is too damn far away
it's better help i call someone better
help you know how many times
people are you know and it's you know
the way people act
can you
speak they need therapy that's what i'm
getting there that's what i'm getting at
this is just the truth
it's the truth in the reality of time
yeah the way things are going now people
can't handle uh reality so they need
therapy to keep them grounded to keep
them healthy keep your relationships and
your all the social fabric of your life
shut up what what what are they doing
if they need this therapy well all right
where are they going well
can i talk about my personal experience
with therapy right now please do
i so better help is it's so much better
because you know i hate leaving the
house yeah you've known this about me
forever yeah you're like a homebody
exactly i'm a homebody
most people are homebodies now most
people work from home most people live
in constant state of fear
exactly so if you're one of those people
which most people are you're not alone
in that that's why uh with better help
you just you could do it right with the
compute old computer or the phone
uh that's what's great about it so
that's why i like doing it rather than
going to traffic and getting pissed off
and finding parking with a therapist
this is much better
so if you're thinking of giving therapy
a try better help's a great option i
think
it's convenient i love it
it's accessible affordable it to me is
my favorite it's my favorite too i love
it so much and it's entirely online you
don't have to do anything no
you can get matched with a therapist
after filling out a brief survey and
switched therapists at any time well can
i tell you about a time i got stuck
focusing on problems instead of
solutions
and it could go uh that's every
conversation i've ever had with you well
can i tell you about how that situation
might go with a different mindset yeah
uh you know it could be tough to train
your brain to stay in like problem
solving mode when faced with like a
challenge in your life you know
no
but when you learn how to find your own
solutions there's no better feeling i'm
fine
you you disagree with that i think it's
fine
well a therapist can help you become a
better problem solver that's really what
life's about it's a series of problems
that are never ending and uh you have to
use your
uh you know uh
your words and your thoughts and your
life's about getting [ __ ]
can i let the folks at home know the yes
please
well when when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you there
when you want to be a better problem
solver therapy can get you there
go to
betterhelp.com
visit betterhelp.com slash timd
betterhelp.com
[Music]
visit
tim
betterhelp.com
today to get ten percent off your first
month that's
betterhelp.com
tim d
i want to talk about this celebrities
now are joining the special forces on a
television show this is what i mean
about who are we who are these shows for
you think they're for smart people
this is a new show what do we have one
of tell the people what they've won so
it's going to be on fox of course it is
yeah it's called special forces yeah
it's sick
well let me let me explain it real quick
so the network announced the ultimate
celebrity social experiment special
force is the ultimate test it's a
working title yes it might not be final
okay it will premiere in january and the
series will put these celebrity recruits
through some of the harshest most
grueling challenges if anyone's gonna
say that i look like a big pumpkin
in the comments
just know
that the person you really hate
is yourself
the series will put the celebrity
recruits through some of the harshest
most grueling challenges from and i this
is good
we take celebrities and we make them do
challenges uh reserved usually for the
special forces from the actual special
forces selection process oh good do we
put them through hell week do they die
there are no videos do they learn how to
drown
there there are no votes or eliminations
uh see the recruits and directing staff
in the photos above and below who's on
the show we got 16 people do we know any
of them former nfl player danny amendola
okay melanie brown of the spice girls oh
boy
aka mel b mel b
uh former bachelorette hannah brown okay
chef tyler florence
i know about you
yeah i don't think i know them i'm
unimpressed by him doesn't he have a
partnership with the olive garden i
think so he's a skunk
television personality kate gosselin
john decade plus eight ah yes they're
not the rapists right or are they that
is uh 23 and counting or whatever okay
so how many it is i forgot i forget
which family we profile turned out to be
the uh rapists the duggars the duggars
uh incestual yeah right in sexual
rapists that we watched for many years
or some people did
uh you have nba player dwight howard i
know him okay he may do well oh singer
montel jordan okay
this is how we do
uh free skier gus kenworthy it's amazing
what people will do to get back on top
and i get it because you're like we're
doing a challenge it's called special
forces all their agents call them and go
listen you people don't have anything
going on
yes or yes and then they go yeah
there's a new show
where celebrities compete in challenges
that are very tough and they're
physically grueling and it might be fun
for you to just crawl around in the mud
and it's i i think that's good
there's a couple on here what they
should do
is let them
when they're done with this do something
like the real special forces would do
they should let tyler florence and mel b
or whoever the hell comes out on top
parachute into a small village and kill
a family
because we have intelligence that says
that the father is involved in an isis
uh related group
that's trying to destabilize a region
that we have economic interests in so
mel b
gets to parachute out of a helicopter
and crawl
on the ground
and then
kill an entire family of people by
planting explosives and then tyler
florence is like all right let's do it
and they watch this they light up this
village and this village burns to the
ground
that's the finale of the show
mel b from the spice girls has to cut
like she holds she's got like this
ten-year-old girl and she's got a knife
to her throat and she tells the father
she goes tell us what you know
and the father goes i will not and then
she just cuts the daughter's throat and
the daughter bleeds out and then mel b
throws her body
and it's like special forces
do celebrities have what it takes to
kill people
do celebrities have what it takes to
kill children
by the way i left the last two people
are the best you have anthony scaramucci
remember yeah white house communication
director and then you have uh jamie lynn
spears so those are the two does it does
it hurt the trump administration that
many of the people that were in it are
now appearing on shows like special
forces
and then [ __ ] jamie lynn spears
yeah
rat [ __ ]
my point
only folks is that uh you know if you
have anything going on intellectually
you just better you better you better
get ready for the next 30 to 50 years
you better get ready for the next 30 to
50 years you must retreat you're gonna
watch old movies
you're gonna read books
you're gonna kind of disengage
you might go get property outside
you know
just do your own thing because
the movements that are going to keep
popping up are going to get stupider and
stupider
and dumber and dumber and the symbols
and the things that people embrace are
going to get dumber and dumber up unto
the point where it's full on idiot
idiocracy the movie we may be there now
and you know to be honest we may just
we're going to eventually get there um
where everybody is really really dumb
and it's never surprising what's going
to be surprising is how dumb wealthy
people are because wealthy people are
going to be really really terrified
because everybody's a social animal
everybody conforms to a certain degree
so rich people are going to understand
that in order to keep a lid
on everything and in order to control
the masses they too are going to have to
get really really dumb and not
articulate complex visions and ideas for
society
they're going to have to dumb everything
down to just stay a little bit ahead of
this
just blob of people
it's coming
it's here yeah because i think this will
probably work as a recruitment tool
which is probably the what special
forces that's probably the whole
nobody's gonna be recruited
to do what i know these go oh i like you
know i like mel b i see her you know
climbing into the helicopter maybe i'll
uh become one of the guys that's over
there in the middle east you know no i
think no nothing works like that anymore
nothing works like that anymore nobody's
going to be recruit nobody really wants
to join the is the thing about the
military no one really wants to join it
anymore
we just like that people are in it
nobody's who's doing like
some people i guess people
certain people are joining it but
recruitment's dipped yeah it's dipped
it's dipped
it's drones now it's all yeah well you
know listen obviously we need people in
the military but like
you know
i hook up with this guy from the
military he's like his 24 year old dude
and here's the thing about him
he
he's
how do i describe
him he's like an inanimate object he's
so
he's like
like if you
imagine sucking off a chair
imagine like sucking the leg of a chair
until like wood shavings came out
that's his head
he's so
like he has no
he's like almost non-verbal
he's not like
he's not like medically don't like be
like oh tim dylan's having sex with the
rhetoric he's in the military he's
clearly not [ __ ]
but he's like kind of non-verbal
and is like
just so
like his job is to die
his job is to be a body
to be thrown
into a conflict which greater wealth
your men have planned
that is his job his job
is to bravely
charge
an ongoing over like he doesn't
have a clue
he doesn't know anything he knows his
little
job which i don't know what it even is
i don't know what he does
but the point is and this is
not uh he doesn't listen to the show but
the point is that if he is listening to
the show this isn't offensive
i'm not if that being a dick
he's
doe
look if i said to you
describe a deck
a deck
like a wood deck
which is a dull part of the house right
it's planks of wood
it would be so much easier than to
describe him like my teak deck that i
have in the hamptons i could spend at 40
minutes talking about teak wood and how
it weathers and gets gray and the rain
and everything and the debt i i could
not describe this guy for more than
eight seconds nine seconds
if i had to
i got him a burrito once and he went
it's big
like he's but that's who's in the
military
because it doesn't make any sense to
join the military but we need you to do
it so please do it if you're thinking
about it get in there but most people it
doesn't make any sense because they
start thinking about
what they're going to do so most people
just go to freedom fast because it's you
feel like you're in the military that's
fine
you can be fat
you can be you can drive drunk
and you just go to freedom fest and you
go
[Music]
and you don't actually have to do any
sit-ups or go somewhere uh with uh food
you don't understand
you don't have to go to a foreign
country just go to freedom for who wants
to go to the military when you go to
freedom fast
[Music]
and you're like
just go to the field
eric trump to go see eric trump in the
field
what life are you living
imagine spending one minute of it
watching gutsy or seeing eric trump in
the field
well you're both sides that's what you
do you just you're a fence sitter you
got both set yeah they're hot they're
both bad you dumb [ __ ]
how dumb are you leave the country
i'm unimpressed by anyone who hasn't
left the country permanently
i'm only impressed by people who fled
this country
really like if i go to dinner with you
and you go i fled
i go i'm impressed by you now
you've impressed me
doesn't mean i'm going to do it i'm not
going to do it i'll go down with the
ship but i'm impressed only by people
who fled the country
permanently gone
can't find them
that's who i'm impressed by people go
yeah [ __ ] all that
but
we'll be back in our studio
we'll be back in our studio next week
we're closing up the house out east
you know it's the summer and the summer
has ended and the summer ends
and the fall begins
and this is
this is a brilliant
thing
and i love the fall the fall is probably
one of my favorite seasons what is your
favorite season
probably summer
and why i mean you hate swimming you
hate the beach i mean why why do you
like why do you even like summer you
freak i like the sun and uh shut up
it's sun it's sunny everywhere in that
dirt [ __ ] patch you're from
it's never not sun
i like the fall
because it's it to me it's there it's
beautiful and it it you you become
conscious of time
become conscious of time in the fall and
become every idiot you have to suffer
through
every [ __ ] every person that steals a
minute of your day with their nonsense
whether they're a friend family
colleague i don't care who it is be
conscious of that this fall
because you know just be conscious of
every minute where somebody's stealing
your life with their insanity and you go
i don't if their insanity's amusing i'm
all for it i've been friends with people
i've wasted hours and hours of my life
listening to babbling psychopaths
because they're entertaining and i've
told you many of
what they've said and it's funny and but
if they're not entertaining just
you know
but it's a great season october
halloween we've got a line of merch
i mean is this the nicest thing you've
ever seen
oh by far yeah talk to your i
have never seen clothing like this in my
life i'm not kidding i'm not kidding
this isn't a joke
i've never seen
clothing like this in my life it's to me
it's so
it's it's
it's
epic
and it stays
it's it's amazing and it can be worn
in all seasons in all climates
which many clothes cannot be
it is not a particular style
it's timeless
and it has a feeling no yes yeah yeah it
is i'm imagining someone 100 years from
now wearing it
no it actually would work it actually
will work and people will wear it 100
years from now and they'll speak of
these days
and and
people will go
what was it like then it'll go it's a
real knife fight out there or so we were
told
but it's it's really beautiful merch and
and and and we are
you know
going to be introducing this very
shortly
and we're we're
we're hoping that
people enjoy it
as much as we do because you worked very
hard now you emailed the designer i did
a few times so to me i
i don't want to understate his role
in the operation and what we do
so many people dismiss you
because they just look at what you do
and go what
but
really the reality of it is that behind
the scenes
you're doing so much
and one of the things you've done
is send a three or four sentence email
to the designer of this merch with the
vision for the with the vision for the
mercy so we both kind of came up with
right i think so right you had one i had
one
right
and
it's important to me that you buy the
merch
it really is it is it is important that
all of you listening by the merch
and i don't want to hear nothing
inflation's going down the price of gas
is going down i don't want to hear
nothing
i don't want to hear that your kid is
sick
your mother-in-law fell
the job's not what it used to be
the hours are getting crunched the
neighborhood's changing the taxes are up
the water's brown you got a pain in your
lower back
i don't want to hear that you're
vomiting and [ __ ] more than you used
to that you wake up in the middle of the
night shivering
i don't want to hear that you don't have
anything to believe and your kids hate
you because you can't provide them with
the style of life that their friends
have i don't want to hear that you can't
get hard to [ __ ] your wife because she's
fat now because she's eating our poison
food
i don't want to hear that you can only
jerk off to women getting beaten on the
internet because you resent your wife
because she finished college and you
didn't
i don't want to hear that you have three
dogs and two of them need operations and
you can't afford it and one of them's
starting to smell
i don't want to hear that your father
doesn't look you in the eye because he's
ashamed of the man that you've become
i don't want to hear any of that
i want you to go buy this merch
and i want you to wear
it and all those problems are [ __ ]
minuscule when you're supporting a
podcast you like
that you enjoy
and people go what is that and you tell
them oh it's a show i like
i think how's your wife go let's talk
about something
that's
beautiful
let's talk about art
let's talk about
a couple of guys that sit in a room and
do their hot takes every week that i
like i like it i like it
it's my time i sit in my car and i get
high and i listen to it i drink and that
[ __ ] knows it's my time she doesn't
come out to see me and if she did man i
picture it i picture her coming out on
that front porch i picture her going
stop listening to that fat [ __ ] and
raise your kids and i said i'll just
[ __ ] i'll reverse right into that fat
[ __ ]
but she never comes outside
because she's watching gutsy
she's watching hillary clinton
talk to a reverend
about her very tough decision to stay
married
and she's drinking wine
in our back room and she can't even hear
me
and i'm out there tinkering in the
garage tinkering fixing it finding it
out and the kids they run by and they go
what are you doing and they go ah yeah
they pay me no mind they pay me no mind
and
they pay me no mind
that's okay
that's okay because i got a pot i got a
podcast that i like
i got a podcast that i enjoy i got two
boys whose talk the [ __ ] i like
i don't care
what this family ends up doing this
family's not gonna produce
generations of wealth it's not gonna
produce
happy people it will end
my kids may not have kids and if they
have kids i worry even more
about it
this will end it will end in juvenile
hall it will end in small claims court
it will end in family court it will end
with addicts with four days of sobriety
scraping the skin off their arms trying
not to [ __ ] go to the 7-eleven
parking lot and buy another blue
to just get them back to even it'll end
in a suburb of schenectady new york
it'll end in schohary county it'll end
in albany in the back of a catering hall
it'll end
bad
it'll end at a funeral we can't afford
it'll end going into the ground with a
couple of bar buddies standing around
checking their watches it ends bad but
[ __ ] it i got a podcast today
with a couple of boys that i like
and they're talking about hillary
clinton
on the internet
and don't kid yourself that means
something to me because my family hates
me and i have no money
and i wish i was dead every minute of
every day
but today
i got a podcast to listen to
and they just said there's merch
they actually just said there's gonna be
merch
they said there's and my wife's gonna
fight about it because we have an
emergency only account
like the last time we used it is when my
son was accused of rape he didn't do it
he was dating a woman and she was taking
liberties with the truth and he was
accused of rape and we had to bail him
out this is before the nobel law but
before the nobel we had to bail my son
out who was accused of rape by his
on-again off-again girlfriend who said
he came over the house and had his way
with her and he assured us that he had
not done that but we had to bail him out
and we used the emergency fund the other
time we used it is when my car broke
down my wife was using my car she's a
server at a local rest stop
and
she had to fix the car with the
emergency fund
we've reserved it for those types of
things son
sons problems and the wife needing to
get to work
but i swear to god
if i don't get that merch
if i don't support
this guy
yes he has three houses he deserves
eight he deserves aid and i'll tell that
to my wife my fat wife when she looks at
me goes do you think he needs more you
don't know what he needs
he's not like us
he's not like us he was raised in a
different
time in a different place
and this and this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] will look at me and she'll go
how dare you spend our [ __ ] money on
merch for this big this fat pig and i'll
say to her
you know what
that's it
this ain't working
and she's gonna go we don't have enough
money for divorce i'm gonna go i'm not
talking about a divorce
this ain't working anymore none of it
the air the water the soil i feel like
i'm on an alien [ __ ] planet
so i'm going to take my tim dillon show
hoodie and i'm going to put it on
and i'm going to go out
and i'm going to listen to free bird in
my truck one more time
and then i'm going to blow my brains out
and drench that hoodie in blood
and i'm going to have you and the kids
find me you ungrateful
grating and horrible shrew
i'm gonna have you and the kids find me
and and the next day
like clockwork
they slept through the gunshot
because they were all [ __ ] up
on their sleeping pills and their booze
but they walked outside they didn't hear
the old man
they didn't hear him tinkering in the
garage
they didn't hear him they didn't smell
the morning cigarette
they just went up to the car
and they saw the blood splattered
all over the front seat the old man was
dead
he was in his favorite merch
he was in the merch
of his favorite podcast
and they buried him in it and they
fought with the undertakers you're not
gonna bury him in a bloody hoodie you go
yes we are
bury him in that bloody hoodie
so my hope is that no matter where you
are in your life
you buy this merchandise
because it is it is important
and it is beautiful
we put the time in ben emailed the
designer
i was on the email as well i don't
really check the emails but i'm on it as
well
even if you're going to kill yourself in
front of your family
as many as i imagine many of you i
imagine 30 of the people who listen to
the show are going to do exactly that
probably before new year's
quite frankly
i just hope that you do it
in the tim dylan show merchandise
because it is beautiful
because there's here's one thing
it's gutsy
you know who hillary clinton should have
had on that show vince foster's wife
i don't know if he was married he
probably was
we want to thank our friends at gas
digital studios we want to thank what's
it what's your name the producer uh
francis right francis i want to thank
francis
we want to thank all the moms and dads
out there and all the families that are
listening to this on their way to
freedom fest
all the families out there in this great
nation you know i'm humbled
and inspired every day
when i hear about the stories of
the medicare fraud
and people that are taking advantage of
others
and people that are faking their own
deaths
i i'm so happy about i say to myself you
know it's [ __ ] we're still fighting
we're still kicking
we're still kicking
and that's beautiful but
i think i've done a decent job selling
the merch
and we're going to launch it soon mo
[ __ ] you can sign up at
timdilliancomedy.com how about you go
and sign the [ __ ] up at
timdylandcomedy.com you go sign up right
now because i'll tell you right now
it's a it's really beautiful
we should do a tour of like four cities
in upstate new york and just call it
like hell on earth
the hell on earth tour and we just do
like binghamton buffalo yes
schenectady it might be fun to just do a
week like right by halloween yes and
call it the hell on earth tour it'd be
great i think we might do that there's
nothing better
than that area in the like halloween
it's halloween all year round but i like
the cheesecake factory in syracuse i
like those areas
yeah we went to that right yeah it was
great yeah it was good phenomenal yeah
it's good
all right everybody
stay focused